Anger around,
privately held with a lot of us go
around feeling quite enraged,
angry,
privately about the way that I love
lives have gone.
My task today is to turn that into
sadness.
If we,
if we managed to turn rage into grief,
we will have made psychological progress
and this is the task today is behind
rage very often is an unusual quality
because we tend to feed the hungry.
People are sort of dark and pessimistic
characters absolutely not scratch the
surface of any regularly angry person
and you will find a wild optimist.
It is in fact that drives range.
I think of the person who screens every
time they can't find their housekeeper
or every time they get stuck in traffic.
These unfortunate characters are
evincing,
a curious but reckless faith in a world
in which keys never go astray.
The roads are mysteriously traffic free.
It is hope that is turbocharging rage.
So if were to get a little bit less sad,
uh,
and as a little less angry about our
love lives,
we will have to diminish.
Some of the reason is that all of us
will not manage to find the right
person,
but we will probably all of us manage to
find a good enough so and that's
success.
In short,
we don't know very much how to love and
it sounds very odd because it actually.
Somebody said,
you look,
all of us probably in this room would
probably need to go to a school of law
with a school of love.
Love is just an instinct.
No,
it's not.
It's a skill and it's a skill that needs
to be learned and it's a skill of it.
Our society refuses to consider as a
skill.
We are meant to always just follow our
feelings.
If you keep following your feelings,
you will almost certainly make a big
mistake in your life.
What is love?
Ultimately?
Love,
I believe is something.
First of all,
there's a distinction between loving and
being loved.
We all start off in life by knowing a
lot about being loved.
Being loved is the funded.
Uh,
that's when somebody brings you
something on a tray and ask you how your
day at school went to federal.
And we grow up thinking that that is
what's going to happen in an adult
relationship.
We can be forgiven for that.
It's an understandable mistake,
but it's a very tragic mistake and it
leads us not to pay attention to the
other side of the equation which is to
love.
And what does it really mean to love,
to love ultimately is to have the
willingness to interpret someone's on
the surface,
not very appealing behavior in order to
find more benevolent reasons why it may
be unfolding.
In other words,
to love someone is to apply charity and
generosity of interpretation.
Problem is we live in a romantic culture
that privileges impulse and when it
comes to love,
something tricky occurs because you
don't have to be a paid up believer in
psychotherapy or psychoanalysis to
realize that the way we love as adults
sits on top of our early childhood
experiences and in early childhood.
The way that we learned about love was
not just via experiences of tenderness
and kindness and generosity.
The love that we would have tasted his
children will also be bound up with
experiences of being let down,
being humiliated.
Maybe being with a parent who treated us
very harshly scolded us or made us feel
small in some way.
In other words,
quite a lot about our early experiences
of love,
a bound up with various kinds of
suffering.
Now something quite bad happens when we
start to go out into the adult world and
start to choose love partners.
We think we're out to find partners who
will make us happy,
but we were out to find partners who
will feel familiar and that may be a
very different thing.